so I had like 40 minutes of content and
people could bug bug me after they want
more stuff so my area of interest so I
build a couple things I build these kind
of characters virtual humans we call
them but then my main interest is trying
to understand what the role emotion
plays in the context of this kind of
technology
now technologies evoke a lot of emotion
recently Stanford Maeby's one of the
Centers of that and it's actually
interesting technology the threats to
our identity the technology creates
actually shapes the way we think of
ourselves so traditionally we thought of
humans are better than others because
we're smart we use language but now
we're increasingly willing to say that
machines can be smart and so we're
starting to shift now where we identify
ourselves is special because we still
have emotion at least and so part of my
job is to get rid of that illusion so
there's a lot of research and interest
in computer science now how do we make
machines emotionally intelligent and
there's a lot of applications driving
that speaking of driving this is a
application in California where there's
a company that's trying to make a
machine that can detect I'm getting
angry in my car and give me a little
massage to try to calm me down sitting
to mellow at notre-dame he's looking at
how can you detect a student's effect
and regulate the kind of material we're
presenting to them to keep them not
frustrated but also not bored some of
the stuff you'll see me talking about
today is could we use this kind of
technology actually to teach us to be
more human so teach people better how to
better recognize emotion or understand
other person's emotion there's a lot of
interest in using effect to persuade
people to do various things so Timbuk
Martin northeastern has been using
effect to try to get people to take
their medicine for example in medical
settings and this little product here if
you smile it's well known if you smile
that makes you happier and so if you
smile it'll give you a candy bar and now
you'll like this product even better
of course also we do a lot of things as
people to create emotions and others
their artifacts like movies and food and
increasing the machines are trying to do
this as well this is some work in my lab
I want to give an example of a machine
that understands and tries to use
emotion this is Ellie she's part of a
project that DARPA funded and their
question was could we use technology to
reach soldiers who have PTSD that don't
want to talk about it part of the
problem with PTSD is a stigmatizing
condition soldiers don't want to admit
they're weak and the question that the
the funder rushed Schilling was
interested in is could people would they
be more comfortable talking to something
like this and this was kind of weird to
me as a project because if you look at
the disclosure literature there's one
lighter research that says that people
are more honest and willing to disclose
information to computer forms but
there's another line of research that
says that people are more willing to
disclose if you establish some kind of
rapport and connection and draw people
out and I was kind of fascinated what do
you put those two things together does
it be the best of both worlds or the
worst of both worlds and fortunately for
us we have some evidence that actually
people are more willing to disclose
honest information about their mental
health to this kind of character than
they would to either a computer form or
another person but I'm not going to talk
about that so much today I'm gonna talk
about the technology underlying it so
let me just play a little example of
this interaction hi I'm Ellie thanks for
coming in today I was created to talk to
people in a safe and secure environment
I'm not a therapist but I'm here to
learn about people and would love to
learn about you I'll ask a few questions
to get us started and please feel free
to tell me anything your answers are
totally confidential are you okay with
this yes so how are you doing today I'm
doing well that's good where are you
from originally I'm from Los Angeles oh
I'm from LA myself
it's true just to show a few things what
you're seeing on the on the left here is
actually what the character can see of
the person and so this blue grid that's
actually tracking the facial expressions
imposed on this on this person actually
kinda looks like Jeremy a little bit
we're also looking at the effect that
people are communicating the audio
signal we have a Kinect here so we can
look at postures we can do things like
our people fidgeting or these are called
self adaptors turned out to be very
diagnostic we can recognize the words
and then do things like sentiment
analysis on the text and then you have
this character here it's showing facial
expressions it's showing postures and
more importantly it's doing this kind of
contingent moment-to-moment feedback
that people do when they're being
attentive so like LIF you nod and smile
as I'm talking I'll give a better talk
and similarly if she nods and smiles or
shows concern at the right point it
draws people out all this in this case
was to try to get at can we get
information about depression both by
drawing people out having to say more
work more words about their condition
but also by using all these kind of non
verbal emotional signals to see if they
correlate with certain aspects of
depression and PTSD now that kind of
technology in general is associated with
this emerging field called affective
computing there's now there's a journal
it's been out about seven years there's
a society associated with it and just if
you're interested there's a couple
meetings coming up soon and the Society
for effective science this is going to
be a pre conference on affective
computing on the first day and then our
big conference will be in San Antonio
this year and in the fall I'm going to
basically touch on this talk three
aspects of affective computing as it
rises it in my own work and one is
really the relationship between effect
and individual cognition so what is the
antecedent where does emotion come from
and a person how does it influence their
decision-making and can you make a
machine that can predict those kind of
influences and simulate them in a
certain circumstances a second thing
I'll touch on is emotion and social
cognition so how do people
to another person's emotions but more
interesting from my standpoint if a
computer shows an emotion would that
influence people in similar ways or
differently and then assuming that
machine emotion does influence people
the last thing I want to talk about is
how can they use that against us in a
sense so how can a machine use emotion
to get people to do certain things maybe
for themselves to help them take their
medicine but also maybe sell them more
expensive cars now a couple of themes
I'll talk about one is that and usually
in artificial intelligence we build on
this irrational tradition of of how
people or how machines should think
here's a prototypical example and in
reality people are kind of more like
this right and that has certain kinds of
consequences some are societal
consequences and AI would benefit from
having a better understanding or
awareness of how emotion Telegraph's
actions we might take what also
influences the kind of decisions we make
another theme I want to really emphasize
and Jeremy touched on this is the
importance of interdisciplinary research
and so what you'll see throughout my
talk is I'm very grounded in the
theories underlying human emotion but
then I try to take those theories and
reconstitute them with in computational
artifacts and then have people interact
with those artifacts and through
empirical research both improve the
artifacts but in some cases make
contributions to psychological theory ok
so first thing I want to talk about and
this is some of the early work I did is
how if we want to build a character like
Ellie here and you're interacting with
it how does Ellie know what emotions
would be appropriate to show in a
certain situation where do motions come
from in people and this is work I've
done through many years with my close
colleague Stacy Marcello who's now at
Northeastern University and I've been
very influenced by a theoretical
perspective called appraisal theory and
I think if you're a computer scientists
appraisal Theory for some reasons you'll
see in a moment is actually a very nice
theory for building computational
artifacts but in a kind of brief
overview the ways the theory argues is
that emotion is this relational
construct it arises not just from
things inside of us but the relationship
between things inside of us in events in
the world so let's say I want to be a
mad scientist and I fail my first math
test
then phrasal Theory argues I judged the
relationship between that event and my
goals along certain dimensions was it
good or bad probably bad did I expect to
fail the test how much control do I have
over it and who do I blame myself or the
teacher for example and based on those
patterns of appraisals that will tend to
elicit certain emotional responses but
further it'll help shape how I respond
to that emotional event so if I feel I
have control over that situation I may
double down hire a tutor or try to do
better next time or I may decide I have
no control over what's going on in this
classroom and join a band give up my
goal of being a mad scientist now if
you're a computer scientists what you
should notice is these kind of what are
called appraisal variables actually map
on pretty closely to some well
understood concepts in computer science
like utility probability planning credit
assignment and so part of what we did
stacey and myself is rican straizo
constructs into these well understood
concepts in computer science and so we
basically showed how to remap different
kinds of praise over bowls into well
understood things like planning and
decision theory and so you could map in
say an agent's goals and then have it in
a out AI algorithm reason about how are
the consequences of these events
impacting an agent's goals and then we
had these shallow automatic rules that
would fire over the syntactic structure
and calculate what these appraisals are
so basically as the planner was doing
its thing and reasoning about goals and
coming up with plans for how to achieve
its goals or reason about threats to
those plans you kind of automatically
get these appraisals popping out of what
would be a plausible emotion for this
agent to feel based on what it's
thinking about at the moment
and then these emotions essentially
served as search control knowledge that
would bias how the AI algorithm work
with a focus on perception what kind of
plans seemed most promising and as it
did then planning based on that search
control and changed the contents of
working memory came up with different
ways to solve its goals you'd
automatically for free
see these emotions change over time so
you'd actually get this kind of nice
dynamic coupling between beliefs desires
intentions of the agent leading to these
emotional praises and those appraisals
and shaping the actions that did and
what was nice and important about this
model was its domain independent so all
this stuff was acting on the syntax of
these representations and then you can
just throw in your particular domain
theory for a particular domain and you
kind of get the emotions for free now
what can you do with this kind of model
some of what you could do is you can see
does is it predictive of what humans
might do in similar situations and so
some of the more psychological work we
did was to take common situations and
code them in the model and see if people
in fact behaved in the similar way to
the model predicted and we've done this
in some like common life situations a
lot of stuff with games so we had people
play things like battleship and word
puzzles and stuff and some moral
judgments let me just give a quick
example of one of these this is some of
the work of when Gmail one of my PhD
students former PhD students where she
would take these common moral dilemmas
and try to encode them into the model
and reason about who would you be mad at
in this situation so in this case here's
a CEO that wants to do something and his
VP says it'll increase profits but harm
the environment the CEO says I don't
care let's do it anyway and the
environment is harmed and what the model
would predict is that you would tend to
be more angry at the CEO than the VP but
then you could also because you have
this model you can kind of reason
backwards from the model and say well
what would you need to change in the
situations change the way who you'd be
mad at and so then she took both the
original situations and these new
hypotheticals that were generated
automatically from the model gave them
the people and showed that the people's
judgments correspond to what the model
predicted so that was kind of nice
now a lot of what I'm paid to do though
is to build these simulations of people
that interact in a variety of different
circumstance and so a lot of the work
we've done with the model is tried to
show that adding this model into a
system would make it act in a more
human-like or believable way and so in a
request a variety of applications
lotty's are military funded applications
so put a soldier in a situation where
they're interacting with people and
they're responding emotionally and a lot
of the focus at that point was to try to
say we need a motion because it makes
these characters more believable and so
that's what we were able to show we put
these characters and they respond
emotionally in a way that seemed
believable and so that's what a lot of
the work we've done on the cognitive
aspect of the model had been but I guess
it was not just satisfied to say emotion
makes things more believable I was
curious if people actually responded to
these characters as they might to
another person if they were showing an
emotion in that context and so the next
kind of phase of the work I focused on
this is with my former PhD student and
he did a postdoc with Peter carnivals
social psychologist at USC was how do
people respond to a machine that is
creating an emotion at them and the
theory that we developed to think about
this we call reverse appraisal theory
and it kind of works like this so as I
just mentioned appraisal Theory argues
that emotion arises from how a person
interprets an event visa vie their goals
and so imagine I'm walking down a street
and I see a robot approaching me and the
robot steps on my foot okay and then the
robot smiles
okay what does that tell you well what
we argue is that what you're basically
when you see someone show an emotional
expression which you want to do is make
sense of it essentially in terms of this
appraisal Theory so you're saying is
okay he's my
he probably has a bad goal probably
wants to hurt me okay and that's
essentially what reverse appraisal
theory argues is that when you see an
emotion in the context of some event you
try to invent what would be the goal
that would explain that emotion from
arising let me give you a little more
concrete example imagine you're playing
something called the iterated prisoner's
dilemma game with the robot Einstein in
this case so who knows what the
prisoner's dilemma is and most of you
prisoner's dilemma is this evil game
invented by economists to look at how do
people make social decisions and it's
constructed in such a way that there's
an economic incentive to cooperate with
your partner okay so you get the most
money in this game if you cooperate you
choose a cooperative choice however it's
an incentive structure is such that if
you choose to cooperate and they choose
to be non cooperative they make a lot of
money so there's this temptation for
them to screw you in a fear that you'll
be screwed and in fact the rational
thing to do is to not cooperate and
although you end up with less money
you're not going to be screwed over by
the other guy now turns out when people
actually play this game they cooperate
much more than we'd be predicted by
rational models and it's been argued
that emotion plays an important role in
how people resolve this dilemma and in
particular I'm interested and others
have been looked at how do emotional
signaling help people solve this problem
so imagine we allow our robot to signal
and we're playing this game and these
smiles do you want to cooperate with him
so you're probably focused on the
morphology of this smile thinking is not
trustworthy but actually I talked about
the information content and the
information content is should you smile
should you cooperate with him well it
depends on the context of where that
smile arose is what we're arguing so if
we play this game and we manage to
cooperate together and he smiles then
you think okay he probably has good
intentions and I should continue to
cooperate on the other hand if we're
playing this game and he just exploited
and he smiles that probably tells me
something very different that maybe he's
not such a good robot and I shouldn't
trust him the next round okay and so to
test this what we did was we basically
created two agents two robots that we
gave them different goals one was a goal
of cooperation and one was goal of
competition and we ran that goal through
appraisal theory to calculate what
emotion should you show in all the
possible four states of the prisoner's
dilemma game and so if you're
cooperative and we cooperate you should
be happy and smile if for whatever
reason you screw over your opponent but
you want to be cooperative you should
feel guilty on the other hand if you're
competitive
you screwed successfully screwed up your
opponent you should be happy and smile
but if you passed up the upper tako
operated and you failed this will screw
them over you should feel guilty because
you've passed up the opportunity to make
some more money and so we created this
matrix of expressions now both agents
actually played exactly the same way
they just played tit for tat and so in
some sense the only difference is you
should see between how people play these
two agents is based on their impression
of what the other agent will do and
that's determined by these emotional
expressions and we hypothesized that
people to recover the goals of the agent
by these patterns of facial expressions
and that would lead them to either
cooperate or not cooperate no you're an
example what this looks like so here's a
woman playing a cooperative agent and
she starts out and she exploits the
agent and the agent shows displeasure at
this she tries to repair the
relationship so she cooperates the
agents playing tit for tat so it
actually screws her back but it looks
sad
and Jen she persists in cooperating and
they manage to meet mutual cooperation
and of course that's one nice anecdote
by the best one but if you look at
groups of people what you see is that
people actually quickly discover or they
infer intent based on these patterns
facial expressions and they cooperate
much more with the agent that shows this
cooperative pattern of emotions as
opposed to one that shows a competitive
pattern of emotions and through a number
of other studies doing mediation
analysis both experimentally and
statistically we can show what's really
going on or seems to be going on here is
that people see the pattern of
expression from that they infer how the
other is appraising the situation and
whether their goal is competitive or
cooperative and then they change their
behavior accordingly okay
now that's with a fairly simple you know
robot like thing it's doing a very
simple script it's probably easy for
people to figure out what the pattern is
so we wanted to also see do people
really do this when they're interacting
with each other and so one way we did
this is we basically had people play a
version of prisoner's dilemma over Skype
so here if you're the player you see
yourself and you see your opponent your
opponent just screws you over and then
you can communicate back to them in this
case you couldn't talk all you could
communicate is non-verbally and we
wanted to see if those nonverbal signals
were informative both of what people
wanted to do but how others respond to
those signals and what we're able to do
with the state is we can automatically
synchronize and track people's facial
expressions synchronize that with what
choices they're making in this game we
can also look at say person's
personality influence this and then we
can try to see is that information
predictive and so what you're saying
here is the state space of iterate
prisons the game it's pretty simple game
only four basic states and people tend
to get stuck in these two equilibrium
where they have joint cooperation or
defection but if you're cooperating then
your opponent can turn around and
exploit you so one thing we're able to
show is that emotions actually are
signaling people's intentions in the
game so if you tend to smile after
mutual cooperation you're more likely to
cooperate in the next round
so the expression does have information
content that is telegraphing what you're
going to do the other thing we can show
is that opponents can pick up on this
information so when you see your
opponents smile turns out you're
actually more likely to screw them over
in the next round so people are using
this information to infer intent and
then make that judgment as to whether to
take advantage of the other person now
it turns out that not you don't have to
use that information to take advantage
of that person you can actually some
people use that information to continue
to cooperate in fact those are the ones
that actually want the most points over
the whole game but locally a lot of
people took advantage of that
information but then they ended up in
this sort of the mutual defection cycle
and they so the good takeaway is that
people that see the other is going to
cooperate and use that for pro-social
motives are the ones that want in this
game okay so the final thing I want to
talk about is can we use this
information to influence human behavior
and this is work I'm doing recently with
some social psychologists in the former
European Union and UK and in Amsterdam
and basically the idea here being that
so as I mentioned before the appraisal
Theory argues that emotion arises from
the surprise oh love how an event is
happening in the world so robot steps on
my foot it has bad intentions
it'll smile okay now the second part
that I mentioned is that observers see
that expression in the context in which
it was elicited and they do this kind of
mentalizing mind-reading on it so they
figure out okay if you smiled in that
context he must have evil intentions and
therefore I know what to do with him now
the trick is that the sender actually
knows that you're doing that to them
they know you're looking at their facial
expressions and so they might express
something different than they actually
feel
and they may do this for actually
pro-social reasons so you know if I
don't like the Jeremy shorts I could say
that this is a really nice shorts dojo
and they match well with the shoes or I
could use them against Jeremy to sell a
more expensive car and so for example if
this robot decides to look guilty after
just stepping on my foot he can make me
think he's a good row button and step on
my foot again right so that's the game
we're gonna play and see can we use this
framework to try to understand something
about human behavior and how people use
a motion strategically to achieve
certain kinds of ends and actually to
study this
I mean if from the psychological
perspective you need to find situations
where people are willing to show
emotions in these very strategic ways
and turns out that one great domain for
studying this is negotiation it's very
easy to get people to spontaneously
manipulate each other in a negotiation
context quickly if you pay the money so
I mean this is a big data set we've been
collecting a little hard to see what's
going on here but these are two people
that are sitting across the table so you
can see this guy down here and this guy
up here and they have these items on the
table and they each have a secret payoff
matrix of how much money they can get
for obtaining each of these blocks and
these blocks have pictures on them like
these uh lamps and chairs and things
like that and they're allowed to just
talk for 15 minutes and come to an
agreement if they fail to come to an
agreement they only get one of these
items so they have an incentive to come
to an agreement but then they also want
to get the best agreement that they can
get so it's a mixed motive situation you
have both interest and exploiting the
other but you have to be able to be
cooperative in order to get any
agreement at all let me just show an
example of these two guys interacting
this can't be broke up okay like I said
before if you get one why do you want
one do you sell half a car I won't
accept it I will only take the three and
if I don't get 2/3 then all I'm going to
do is take the
and that's just gonna keep us out of
stalemate and get nowhere okay and then
if you would so it's a very unpleasant
person I mean he's actually using this
unpleasantness he actually gets the best
deal of anyone that we did in the study
and what he's saying here he's saying if
we don't reach an agreement
we'll both walk away with one block so
give me everything I want or you're only
gonna get one thing so he's using
threats all right and you'll see that a
lot in these negotiation contexts so
within this work the real question I'm
asking is how do people and perhaps
machines figure out if they want to fake
an emotion to achieve a certain social
goal what emotion should they show and
what circumstances and then if you're
the recipient of that if you're getting
and interacting with this person or
machine that's showing possibly fake
emotions how do you know if it's fake or
real how do you solve that problem and
how do you you know incorporate that
into your decision-making process and
that's that an overarching argument I
want to make is that this idea of
appraisal and reverse appraisal can help
you build algorithms to try to solve
these problems so let me give you a more
concrete example so imagine these two
people are trying to figure out how to
partition these items on the table okay
and the woman here on the Left she
really wants apples okay but she doesn't
want oranges she actually loses money if
she takes oranges this guy over here
he's indifferent he wants both of the
things and so if they're rational what
they should do is freely exchange
information assert their preferences
either verbally or non-verbally and then
that they can calculate this or Nash
equilibrium they can find the most
efficient fair way to allocate these
items that maximizes the social good and
allows everyone to come worth about half
the pie and this is the deal that they
would come up with in this case gives
each of them 20 $20 alternatively what
you could do if you're the woman here on
the left you could be a little bit cagey
you could ask a lot of questions what do
you like do you like this do you like
without necessarily revealing what you
want get this guy to reveal what he
wants and then you can say I like
everything - oh well how about this deal
you know it's not really happy about
this deal but I want to be fair okay if
you look closely at this deal what
happens if she gets twice as much stuff
as the other guy but he feels like he
got a good deal he feels like it's a
fair and in efficient partitioning of
the two items so that's what I'm gonna
try to formalize here so she's
misrepresenting what she is interested
in in order to gain material gain and
using some tools from game theory we
tried to represent this as something I'm
calling the misrepresentation game and
the basic idea is how do we convey a
false set of emotions such that you can
maximize your own interest while leaving
the other person to feel like they were
treated fairly
and it's basically you can formalize it
a two stage game the first part I won't
talk about so much but requires
preference elicitation stuff so how do
you most efficiently and effectively
we'll pull out what somebody wants with
the fewest number of questions and then
given that you know what they want then
find a false set of preferences or
emotions to show that leads the other to
feel like they're treated fairly it just
turns out to be a little bit of math
here so this is basically an
optimization problem where you're trying
to is find the best set of emotions to
convey to the other party such that you
maximize your own reward while
simultaneously satisfying certain social
constraints in this case the social
administrators we want to be seen as
fair so we want the other person to
believe that the deal is fair we get the
most and then how do we show a pattern
of emotions that Mac allows us to do
that it turns out you can mathematically
solve that and find what's the optimal
lie in this case under certain
assumptions and it's something we call
the fix pie lie and it's actually known
to people who study negotiation research
and socially the lies like this imagine
that we're trying to divide these items
on the table and my opponent
they like apples best okay and they
don't care about pears I like pears best
agent like Spears best and doesn't like
apples then what the agent should do is
say well it's obvious we both want the
apples which turned out to be what the
person wants the most but I tell you
what I'll give you what you want the
most if I just take the rest of this
stuff and we'll call it even
okay so this is called fixed pie lie
because you're basically pretending like
you're both want the same things
it's a win-lose situation in fact
there's opportunity to grow the pie if
if the agent just said hey I want this
most you'd end up with the same deal
right but in this case you get to take
more of the stuff in the middle and if
you give this solution to people if you
have people interact with a system that
would do this kind of lie what you find
out is they're much more willing to
accept this unfair offer from the agent
that lies and if it was honest or even
if it said nothing about what it wants
and they're more satisfied with their
outcome and they think it was more fair
okay and so what makes this strategy
particularly nasty is that people when
they come to a negotiation they often
assume the other is like them and so it
seems very natural and believable that
this person wants the exact same things
that they do now
that's again this is an agent it's kind
of stylized so do people actually do
that to themselves and so we went back
to this large corpus of people in the
NGO Shane with each other and we tried
to look at how they were communicating
their preferences to the other party and
we found out well there's a lot of bad
Liars but when people follow this
strategy they actually beat their
opponents and there's also some evidence
that what the people that employ this
strategy are high in a certain
personality trait called
Machiavellianism Machiavellianism is a
trait where you endorse the idea that we
should use emotion to manipulate other
people and not necessarily feel bad
about it fortunately for you guys
there's also some evidence that we can
automatically detect those people that
are the Liars in this
and there's a couple ways to do that one
is there's some information about the
morphology or the timing of their facial
expressions that gives us evidence that
they're deceptive but more importantly
in this context what you should notice
about this lie is that the person is
saying they like one thing but they're
doing something different and so there's
this discrepancy between what people
show and say and what they do is pretty
predictive of the fact that there's a
deception going on okay
so so what what should we do with this
and one big question and I'm actually on
a Triple E ethics panel because I'm
interested in what is the ethics behind
it should we build agents that lie to
people and it's not so simple on the one
hand from a financial perspective people
may actually prefer to buy this kind of
agent right because you can show that
this agent will earn you more money if
it negotiates on your behalf and an
agent that's honest and open and in fact
this is a dilemma that's confronted
lawyers so I got led through thinking
about this question to legal ethics
writings about should a lawyer be able
to lie on their clients behalf in a
negotiation and if you look at least in
the United States of the ethical code
that guides lawyers they're not allowed
to lie about certain things but they are
allowed to lie in negotiation about
what's your limit how enthusiastic you
are for certain items under the
understanding that everyone does it and
in fact that's the way that your clients
going to make more money in fact if
you're completely open and honest about
what your client would settle for that
would put you at a conflict of interest
in your client and so you're in
something ethically bound to
misrepresent
in certain ways at least that's the
argument the counter-argument to that is
if whenever you add deception to
negotiation you undermine the social
good so the efficiency of the
negotiation you'll fail to find
solutions that you might have been able
to because you'd miss under
damn what the other party wants but also
there's context where you can show that
being deceptive is actually helps the
social good or imagine a situation where
it's pretty likely in a rescue situation
somebody's going to die and they're
panicking but if you tell them it's very
likely they're gonna live they might
calm down enough so there's actually
some chance of saving them where if
you're completely truthful and so yeah
even ninety percent chance of dying so
there's all these kind of questions
where deception and basically human
politeness often involves a certain
notion of deception right so I don't
know the answer just to say that it's
it's not completely obvious in one of
the my current thinking is we should at
least bind these agents to the same
ethical guidelines that humans that are
fulfilling the same role or held to now
what I'm actually doing with it right
now is I'm using it to drive the
behavior of virtual negotiators and the
idea being if you can practice
negotiation with an agent that's
deceptive maybe you'll learn to be
better at detecting these kind of
deceptive tactics so let me give an
example of the interaction with this so
here you see the items on the table and
they're negotiating over it it's pretty
obvious that we both want the chairs
well how about that that doesn't seem
fair though well not really what do you
think about me getting two chairs and
the clock and you getting one chair and
both plates you'll probably make most of
your profit off of these plates yeah so
I
of course the chairs are worth something
take all three that doesn't seem fair
though so now you see she's doing the
same thing that guy did in the beginning
she's saying give me what I want or we
won't come to an agreement now one thing
is nice about the system is we can
actually automatically extract a number
of statistics about how they're playing
and one of the things I'm working with
right now is a professor in the business
school who teaches negotiation and we're
playing with so here's these negotiation
principles he tries to teach so for
example you do better in a negotiation
if you start with a very ambitious offer
people often come in they want to be
fair and they end up miss community so
the miscommunicating what they really
want but also walking away with less and
you can automatically calculate through
a number of these kind of negotiation
principles to what extent is a student
following them compare them to the rest
of the class you can also track their
facial expressions and look at you know
for example are they communicating what
they think they're communicating through
their emotional expressions okay so what
I try to do in this talk is in the
beginning I try to talk about how you
can build these models of what a person
might likely feel and the moment based
on how events are impacting your goals
and use those models both to predict how
people might react emotionally in
certain kind of contexts what decisions
they make but then drive the behavior of
realistic characters and various
simulations that behave as people do
when they're experiencing emotion I then
kind of try to show that just the fact
that your computer doesn't mean that
people won't react to your emotional
displays and that people use those
emotional displays as information to
figure out what the belief desires
intentions of the other whether the
other is a person or a machine is in
somewhat irrelevant it's that these
emotions convey information that
information is important from driving
social interaction and then finally that
both with people and possibly with
machines that emotion is not
to say that what you think it is and
when you're trying to recognize
someone's emotion you shouldn't strictly
just look at what they're showing on
their face but be aware of what's being
shown on the face may be a
misrepresentation of the actual feeling
often done with express purposes of
manipulating the outcomes in a social
interaction and that both these
techniques can be used to understand how
people do that to perhaps automatically
identify the tells for when that's being
done and possibly have machines do this
themselves both for pro-social and pro
self reasons and the kind of high level
takeaway is is a big advertisement if
your appraisal theorists that this is
the way this is the particular theory of
emotion that's very useful for building
these kind of computational methods now
there's a lot of other stuff I do that I
don't have time to talk about one
interest is kind of in general the
psychology of Technology how do people
relate to technological artifacts and
can the way they relate to other people
give us some insight and into way that
machine should be built or the way they
evoke responses from people do a lot of
work in mental health as you saw at the
beginning and obviously I'm also using
this technology now now to understand
negotiation processes and beginning to
get interested in ethical concerns and
this is my group and I'm happy to talk
about anything else or take questions
[Applause]
so back actually my original thesis
adviser Greg Collins he was a student of
Roger shank and his thesis was analyzing
how people come up with these strategies
in sporting events were basically the
way those techniques work is you set
yourself up where you could go one way
or the other and you allow yourself
I haven't actually but you you probably
can answer that question you have a
whole company around that have you
looked at like this VR let you help
understand tells or yeah so I haven't
thought about in sporting events that's
an interesting question yeah I mean
basically I mean I would guess and what
what you would be should be looking for
in general when you're doing some action
is you're preparing your body to do
something and you try to look for
inconsistencies in you know are you
fully committed to action or you only
showing some aspects of that action and
showing something else that's
inconsistent so like just in that
negotiation tactic there's there's a
discrepancy there that they're doing one
thing but they're also seem to be
preparing to do something else you try
to look for those kind of
inconsistencies yeah so in when we talk
to humans or disclosure illusion to
humans we have some sense of what their
computational limits are because they
have a brain kind of like ours
ish hmm have you looked or seen folks
think about what they expect or think
the eye system is remembering how long
can it have it and whether or not it's
going to opt into other areas of my life
so I haven't directly looked at that
question although some people have
but one thing it's kind of interesting
so the disclosures what we found was a
disclosed the first study where you're
interviewed was what's kind of
fascinating about that finding is that
people come in they sign a consent form
saying researchers will look at this
data and then they could also opt in
about 75% opt in to allow me to share a
video of them with other researchers
across the country and then they have
this camera trained on them right and
then then they're told this is run by an
AI or they're told this is run by a
person in the other room and that last
bit of information seems to be driving
this effect so even though it's some
abstract level they know that they're
not anonymous that immediate belief that
this is an AI somehow that is not
someone in the moment seems to be
important and this doesn't seem to make
any kind of quote/unquote rational sense
and there's a lot of examples of these
where it's the vividness of the
knowledge it's more important than the
knowledge itself which to drive the
interaction now there is a fair amount
of work and anthropomorphism and and
people like gray and Wagner and and I
think it's weights at Northwestern that
look at folk fake folk theories of
machines and what things our machine is
capable of not capable of and a lot of
it boils down to roughly does the
machine have intellect and as they have
an emotion and then certain tasks are
seen to be better suited for those
different kinds of jobs but yeah we
should if we run some more things we
should run a lot more kind of questions
that people's expectations both going in
and afterwards
yeah German so I'm really fascinated
with this idea of leaked emotionless
versus constructed strategic motions and
you talked a little bit about what we
know about how people do that in the
real world this tank men versus
Friedlander's no I'm always trying to
understand
how often you can strategically use
these facial expressions yeah well it's
an all debate and and I guess the debate
argument no one disagrees that people do
it the question is are there really
tells so Fridolin would would be say is
on the extremists saying we never show
what we feel and there's no evolutionary
argument for why we would ever evolve to
show what we feel because we could
always be exploited and versus others
that say there's all this great
evolutionary argument why we should show
what we feel because it allows us to
cooperate and coordinate efficiently so
I don't have a way to settle a debate I
mean there is some evidence and we've
seen some of that evidence in our data
that there are subtle indicators of and
people are good to some extent not great
at detecting faked versus authentic
expressions and some of that comes from
pers fo Van Cleef in the negotiation
context trained people to be method
actors and authentically express anger
versus told them they expressed anger
and the ones that were told hey just
express anger it backfired and they lost
money trying to show anger at
negotiation and there's work on the
temporal dynamics of Facebook so if your
facial expression that worked by Avik
remember if you have a fast onset long
apex and fast offset that's interpreted
as a inauthentic display it's called the
politician smile okay
also there's some from the clinical
literature there's some data that and we
see evidence of this and some of our
data that people engage in what are
called smile controls they do certain
things with their mouth in order to mask
an expression and if you use very rapid
analysis facial expression you often see
there's an onset of a negative
expression that's then quickly masked
over with the smile so I think there are
quote unquote tell
but it's very hard and I haven't seen
good replicable research that reliably
you know shows them in naturalistic
situations let me get hurt a little bit
the question teacher machine to
understand those underlying costs for
the emotional associations we have right
now with his specific toy or stories I
don't know I guess my sense would be
that those are very idiosyncratic to an
individual and that you'd have to I mean
they're probably commonalities and
within a culture to a certain kind of
touchstone artifacts that would tend to
evoke certain kinds of you know a
mother's voice or certain kind of
animals but to a lot of it is probably
it is syncretic to a particular
individual and so you'd have to somehow
get a lot of information about that and
you know observe I mean it's very
increasingly easy to do now you know
observe someone over time and try to
even you know there's a lot of interest
in wireless or experience sampling and
try to get at what is what is changing a
person's mood throughout a day and could
you somehow identify the events that
seem to do that would be one possible
way to go about that I'm not that
familiar with work that's that's an
interesting question I'm not familiar
with that much work trying to do it yeah
um chief with it when I saw the ad for
the word okay yeah I think we talked
about little BOTS actually feeling the
entity further faked out I thought USC
gosh Dumas
is there I'm wondering if he's
interacting with them and then some of
the other questions made me think is he
doing carry style modeling human driven
modeling schizophrenia
right there by Hollywood major at
working with animators that are trying
to realistically overcome the uncanny
valley so this is sort of a other work
at USC questioning collaborators who are
doing stuff like that yeah so I've
touched I mean there's a lot of that
stuff going on you know I said mozzie at
the brain computing great bring
creativity Institute by Antonio we
haven't had a lot of close connection
the the closest so my Institute in
general my Institute we are supposed to
be focused on using virtual reality to
create social experiences for training
and so things like negotiation but we're
also training position to interview a
patient the closest connection with
DiMaggio's group is Andrew Gordon at our
lab also shanks student did a lot of
work and he tries to have machines to do
storytelling and he's been looking at
stories that involve morals or not and
and then they're trying to look at that
those in a magnet to see when people are
reading stories that involve a moral
issues that tend to activate different
kinds of brain activity there's a lot of
connection not with my group well not my
specific group but in our lab in general
with Hollywood and so we hire
professional animators one project I
didn't talk about called gunslinger is
kind of Westworld
so there was a guy who actually wrote
the script for the original Westworld
back in the seventies ER and we built an
interactive saloon with characters and
he brought in cinematographers so
you could see how they created a mood
with lighting as he brought in and we
watched John Ford movies and things and
so there's a lot of attempt to how do
you bring the craft of Hollywood into a
voguing emotion and so I'm more on the
psychological side and interested in
human emotion but there's a lot of
people our Institute that it's in fact
it's much more efficient to cheat right
and to use all these kind of tricks and
sometimes you can see how those tricks
work so we can show Rosetta it's well
known that certain kind of lighting
influences how people interpret facial
expressions in a movie and then you can
have the automatic facial expression
recognition techniques look at a person
in different lighting conditions and
they get fooled the same way so there's
a lot of kind of interesting connections
so well so we have a graphics Apollo
Bewick who actually just left for google
is ran our graphics group and he his he
actually just does a data of intensive
way to do that so they have a device
called a light stage that has basically
a hemisphere of lights and you put
somebody in there and you have these
very high fidelity high speed cameras
and you can capture exactly how your
face looks and how it folds as you move
it and then construct a real aidable
model and then they use those models in
movies so spider-man and all the
spider-man movies and various kinds they
build these digital heads that do all
that and even things like the fact that
you know light goes through your ears or
if I'm standing next to you I look a
little bit purple all that kind of stuff
gets captured in those kind of models
so if you just just captured the
people's final price noticing how could
you presumably be the migrants in the
sentence wait for the AI platform say
it's a the Justice textures not
so good of image processing because
there's so there's a and it just is good
for text or wondered if you put very
simple graphical eyes nose mouth there's
nothing else well it mean it like text
possibly eventually we could it mean it
you only have those elements just for
features facial features um well it
would convey some kind of information
witnessing that one the words people are
saying yeah yeah I feel like I should
start the question just man but I am
curious about what other philosophical
frameworks are you drawing water here
looked into in addition to the legal
ethics as you considering the deception
possibly and artificial engine and or
coding in deception into an artificial
agent future yeah there's a
communitarian view which and actually
this shows up the legal ethics as well
is that that really the we should
construct mechanisms or ethical
frameworks that are focused on the
common good as opposed to the individual
good weird territory right like when you
talked about the apples and the oranges
example I would disagree that the
national equilibrium is the fair choice
because it depends on who put in the
values with utility yeah and if it were
individuals and it's actually fair for
her to have called the apples or as if
it's in society then you go into
complicated questions of communities
adding the who is you know there's like
seven or eight different principles of
fairness there's you know an equity
principle which says if I investment
into this interaction I
get more out there is a quality
principle which is what I'm using right
here there's a need principle if you
need more resources than me I have a
moral obligation to to provide you more
than a fair share and so yeah so okay
and that's a lot of question to that
would be following on his question which
is you know when we talk about human
emotions the ability to model and
possibly manipulate and deceive seems
somehow more fair because there's an
underlying assumption of equality of
access computational skills and
background knowledge right and you can
argue you know to the degree of that but
with a I've now we have well that's not
necessarily true
there could be a machine that perfectly
portrays it has emotions but is a zero
connection right right that and also you
know arguably way more access to a
little faster computational skills for
facial recognition and associations and
college ever Houseman right now yeah
it's
it's one of the subcommittee's I mean I
worry about it
I mean subsets I more I worry more about
market research than military research
in this sense because marketing it's all
about how do we get as much information
possible in the person or to make the
sale and emotion I mean a lot of emotion
researchers hang on marketing
departments because there's a reason for
that so I probably don't think about it
enough and I don't and as a field
probably people are not thinking about
it enough but but that it that is one of
the topics and it's it there's several
topics you know deception there's also
things like you know should you make
machines that actually have emotions and
and should you have machines that stat
try to attempt to establish
relationships with people and does that
undermine real relationships or not
because and actually some of our data we
can show that talking to a character
like Ellie you're let you feel less need
to talk to a person afterwards
so if we call social snacking and so
they satisfy the social need and so that
potentially means that people would be
less pro-social so yeah there's a lot
about the qualifications that need to be
yeah so we use it easier to show that
this two things we mean a lot of the
track of globe
I kind of work more at the understanding
level those low level tracking for face
we use a CNF at CMU and then decide
which Apple just bought and took off the
market but for voice we use it gets
called open year it's something out of
fun Augsburg Germany and we have our own
thing cohdon rep but the step and share
our group does a lot of audio processing
stuff so there's a lot of open source
tools for speech yeah how successful
have these virtual negotiations been
like has the API
yeah the AI succeeded in getting a fair
share so far and what are kind of the
next problems are some blind spots to
hear I'm finding it yeah so the fully
automated one is not particularly good
and then we but we have a well the Poli
automated one that uses natural language
because it has it often and this
understands what's going on and part of
why we added these blocks was because
you have multiple channels as to what's
going on in the worst case the agent
could say show me what you want the we
have a kind of online Mechanical Turk
one that's more menu based in fact we
have a human agent competition where
people can write agents to try to see
how well they do against other people on
that one we have some data that it the
the lying one works pretty well so
within these kind of context but these
are very simple negotiations and in fact
I mean well there's many problems in
negotiation one is that usually
finding good solutions involved some
kind of creativity requires reframing
the problem in a different way or
bringing in things outside the
negotiation entirely so when you put the
people together one of the things we
tried to we tried to force there was no
completely equal way to divide the items
and even though we tried to restrict
this because we wanted to keep a small
domain people had a hard time with that
and they keep inventing all these clever
ways to make it fair so hey you know let
me give you five bucks or you know maybe
we can cut this thing in half or you
know this or neck hit next time and so
there's a lot of stuff around
negotiation that people bring in so that
just beyond the scope of the
intelligence that I have right now so I
think and the professor I'm working with
he would use this system for the very
first module in a negotiation course but
then quickly he gets into concepts that
are just way beyond what we were able to
do yeah is a rule-based system where you
are hard coding the rules have you
explored using deep neural networks to
try to drive the no I haven't but but
obviously that seems to be the good way
to get published these days yeah there's
a lot of people look that's actually a
lot of research in an agent agent
negotiation and they typically use a lot
of its kind of heuristic me there's not
there's no game it's too complicated
usually the way they frame these tasks
there's not a nice simple closed-form
solution but they have these agents sit
in in they don't all they the only way
they communicate is through bidding
they just exchange thousands of bids
back and forth and they try to infer
from that based on the pattern of
concessions that the other
Agence making probably what their
preferences are then they try to
calculate the Pareto frontier and and
then try to negotiate along that and
they'll do these kind of exploratory
offers to try to you know so if I think
the frontier is here I'll give two
equivalent offers to you that are coming
to me and if you like this one better
that gives me some information about
what you want so they usually just kind
of these heuristic approximations of
rational algorithms informed by kind of
game theoretic principles because now
you're you're creating an overlay of a
different kind of signaling than just
the pricing and you're starting to
explore how the emotions in yeah
by having machine machine interactions
you'd explore that space much more
rapidly use the idea of a simulated user
and have these machines interact with
each other but the machines are trying
to portray themselves as embodying human
principles yeah might actually find is
that I mean if you clustered it you
might find that there are emotional
cluster points that are different than
what you see in human interaction yeah
or they're interacting good he got much
better understanding of sort of what's
the range of yeah potential emotions
maybe even emotions and humans don't
typically display the thing but you
might find those for example in the
animal kingdom where the methods of
signaling are different so it serve
opens up the whole issue of what's the
emotional landscape and how do you
rapidly explore yeah so you can have
this like a emotional agent competition
basically they're all competing and
trying out you know exploratory
different strategies and see what kind
of equilibrium is emerge all the
emotional signaling yeah yeah it's an
interesting guy should try that yeah
yeah he's building hardness or image
models so rather than me rather than you
you know because you have access to
facial gestures and everything right
imagine deficits you know hundred
parameter yeah humane in the new
assignment probabilities yeah there's a
guy well the closest I know that's a guy
who use the Brookins and del you doing
like reinforcement learning algorithms
that would be the closest I've seen to
someone who trying to do that most of us
are a little back in the old days exit
system
[Applause]
you